Okay. So the serial fabulist.
New York
Congressman George Santos
has taken on many fake identities
with his fabricated resume
and his shamelessness continues.
He is now compared himself to civil
rights pioneer Rosa Parks.
Its comments
came in a recent podcast interview
where he discussed Senator Mitt Romney
reportedly telling him, quote,
You don't belong here.
Before President Biden's State
of the Union address in February,
Santos invoked
Rosa Parks his name when discussing
what happened. Listen,
I'm going to call them out.
You want to call me a liar?
I'll call you a sellout.
I mean, Mitt Romney,
the man goes to the State of the Union
of the United States
wearing a Ukraine lapel pin,
tells me a Latino gay man
that I shouldn't
sit in the front,
that I should be in the back.
Well, guess what?
Rosa Parks
didn't sit in the back, and neither
am I going to sit in the back.
Oh, snap.
Let's put this into context, shall we?
In 1955,
Rosa Parks was arrested in Montgomery,
Alabama,
for refusing to sit
in the back of the bus
and give up her seat
to a white passenger.
Her act of extraordinary courage
and defiance
led to the Montgomery bus boycott
and is known as
one of the earliest
starting points of the civil
rights movement.
Nearly a year later,
Supreme Court
ruled the city's bus segregation laws
were legal and unconstitutional.
By comparison, Mr.
Santos is awaiting
trial on criminal fraud charges.
He's pleaded not guilty
to a 13 count indictment
and includes allegations
of misusing campaign funds
and lying about his personal
finances on a House disclosure form.
He's also admitted to lying
about his resume and family background.
The first term
congressman's thirst illness
is unclenched, however, and he claims
he will be seeking reelection.
So let's take a look at the numbers,
shall we?
Our senior day
reporter Harry Enten is here
so what is the data?
Show us about how much
to help with polling?
Can I just say that?
I mean, my goodness gracious.
You know, look,
his favorable
rating in his own
district comes in at 7%.
That's not particularly high.
So I like I mean, I'm surprised
that high, to be honest.
Well, you know,
again, you can get 7% of Americans
to agree upon anything.
And in fact,
I have some examples of that right there.
How
many percent believe the Earth is flat?
10% of Americans
believe the Earth is flat.
12% of Americans believe that the U.S.
faked the moon landing.
Oh, well, that's you know.
Yeah, of course.
So obviously. Right.
So the fact is his Stanley
Kubrick filmed it.
Yeah. There we go. That's exactly right.
They did on the set stage.
We did it all for some ridiculous reason.
So I think that gives
you an understanding of
just how unpopular this dude is.
He has fallen behind conspiracy theories.
His support
pocket in New York's third
district is so, so, so small.
And I mean, does
he have fundraising numbers?
Does he put this out?
Yeah, he did for quarter one.
We don't know what his quarter
to fundraising is, but for quarter one,
he raised a little bit more than $5,000
by comparison.
For his Republican challenger.
We know what his quarter
to fundraising is,
and he's raised about $200,000.
So I'm not necessarily
the biggest math genius in the world,
but I believe that is 40 times
about 40 times
as much as the incumbent
representative has.
And that, of course, is ridiculous
because normally
you know, incumbents
raise a lot of money.
In this case,
the incumbent is being far outraised
by Kansas, has great name recognition.
He does have great name recognition.
But sometimes you know,
they say that all news is good news.
Perhaps that's not necessarily
the case in politics
because in this particular case,
that news seems to be quite negative.
Are there polls about Rosa
Parks as popular?
Yeah, there are. So really there are.
But there's polls about everything.
Come on.
You know, this
you know,
if George Santos is universally disliked
Rosa Parks is universally well-liked,
at least now.
So if you look at Rosa Parks, favorable
rating among Democrats and Republicans,
they hover right at about 90%. Right.
Slightly higher
among Democrats than Republicans.
But the fact is, that's
within a statistical margin of error.
Well, that's at least good to see.
It's good to see.
I come with good news.
Yes.
You know, we have
we have a serial fabulist
who somehow gotten to Congress.
But the fact is,
Rosa Parks, a civil rights
hero, rightfully
so, is still very well-liked.
Well, someone like Jorge Santos
is not just disliked by Democrats.
He's disliked by Republicans
with just a favorable
rating of only 11%
among Republicans in his own district.